en la campaña electoral francesa no
puede desvincularse de la guerra nuclear
ni el presidente macro no está
utilizando esas dos casetas como se dice
aquí esos dos gorros el de presidente y
también el de candidato y a veces se ha
dedicado más bien al de presidente y
dejado de lado el de candidato por lo
mismo ayer volvió a los baños de masaya
que recordemos está bajando las
encuestas aunque sigue siendo el
favorito está bajando y está subiendo
madrid le pena la candidata de la
extrema derecha y la luz me lanzo de la
extrema izquierda que lo sigue en el
tercer lugar él estuvo ayer en dijon se
reunió por los jóvenes pero sobre todo
justamente sus ataques fueron a la
extrema derecha él dijo que las personas
los candidatos extrema derecha le pene y
se muden reale lo que quieren hacer es
dividir a la sociedad dice ellos
finalmente van a terminar juntos y por
lo tanto él se representa como una
alternativa dice de unidad de la derecha
de la izquierda y del centro él dice
para caminar se necesitan dos piernas
una derecha y una izquierda que tienen
que caminar una primero y la otra
después y lo dice justamente porque él
ha sido criticado desde que presentó su
programa para estas elecciones
y presentar medidas sobre todo muy hacia
la derecha así que ayer le dio más
acento a esas hacia la izquierda
hablando de la derecha ha vuelto y
también a la campaña balear y de que es
la candidata de los republicanos
recordemos que estaba con kobe 19 hoy se
hizo un test salió negativo así que
partió hacia el norte a los terrenos de
javier viajan quien fuera su contendor
en las primarias para hablar con los
empresarios mientras tanto erick tseng
el candidato de extrema derecha
polemista hoy se presentó ahí en la
periferia noreste de parís donde como
les anunciábamos ayer ha habido todas
las noches altercados manifestaciones
por la muerte de un hombre a manos de la
policía él dijo que había que marcar que
había que atacar al lumpen dijo que él
iba a erradicar el lumpen aterrorizar a
los terroristas